a new episode of our documentary series
tucker crosston originals out tomorrow
maybe the most dramatic episode we've
done we went to el salvador to take a
look at the deadliest criminal gang
possibly in the world
ms-13 here's part of what we found
these are their cells you can see
they're pretty tightly packed
they're all active members of different
gangs here they're 12 men to a cell
they're pulling them out of the cell
and then going through it forensically
looking for weapons drugs
communications devices any other kind of
contraband tattoo
needles we were just in a cell as they
were doing that
pretty rank this is a bulletin board for
guards and it tells you
how many msn 13
active members are in the cells right
now 427 and according to the people who
run
the prison there have been no murders
we can't verify that one member of ms-13
agreed to sit down with us
in the prison yard i'm doing my sentence
like 25 years in this place
are you still in ms-13 yes i do
would you ever leave not yet
how long were you in the united states
it did like 10 years
how did you get there the train
the episode is called hunting ms-13 el
salvador is getting their crime problems
under control there are lessons believe
it or not in el salvador for
us that's out tomorrow you can watch it
along with other episodes of our
original series on foxnation.com and we
hope you will
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now